you
[Music]
my usual comedy routine is bad it's not
good a lot of self-deprecation a lot
about dating usually like deadpan
topical it's personal and a little dirty
could you do something funny for me
[Music]
[Music]
have you been to a stand-up show before
does this have you ever done this to
yourself
Sebastian tell me what you think is
funny doggies they're just funny in
general I think they're gonna be able to
hear that pretty well what's it like
being so sis what's the like being so
much smaller than everyone else is it so
weird
what's your favorite color crayon yeah
red yeah did you know what's crazy
because the color red is the same thing
is when you read a book and it's like
the English language am i right here
knock knock shows you you know it
already yeah you know what's funny about
this is I signed up for this I was like
oh great I'll be the comedian turns out
I think maybe it's you do you have some
drinks yeah oh no is that not what I was
supposed to be the funny one I'm failing
miserably isn't it crazy when the
teachers like hey stop that she sounds
like hey I'm Peppa Pig oh my god like do
you like farts no you like apple juice
you ever think about how there's no
strawberry juice right it's like what's
that about
what if I sat in my chair all funny-like
like this
maybe there's something it's doing it
for you if you sit here you can have
fruits that you can do for 10 minutes
one two what what can I do that's funny
[Music]
a pirate
okay some part no listen I I feel like
that's a new form of heckling you just
show me your shoes I'll take it
I hear coming the ships the sails bring
up the barge you gotta walk nothing will
make you yeah I know I know everywhere
terribly you know what are you gonna do
when you're not funny
well he gave me some notes I might want
to focus on pirate content maybe some
focus on doggies just not nothing in
general about just doggies in general
please
[Laughter]